everyone's here even though you did some
backbreaking work with snow removal I'm
sure last night or this morning uh
welcome
we have listed
several bills on the executive session
for today but one in particular I wanted
to highlight House Bill 639 we will not
be executing today so if you're here for
that we have scheduled a full committee
work session next Tuesday at 10 A.M
we've heard that there will not be a
house session next Tuesday so we will do
a full committee work session and we've
requested the agencies that were in
attendance at the public hearing to come
back and help us as we do a deep dive on
that bill so we're not going to exec 639
our deadline for that bill is March 30th
so we are tentatively planning to exec
it on Monday March 27th to give us a
little wiggle room if we need it
okay so moving along in the calendar the
next bill is 494.
for some reason I don't get it gavel
regularly hold on
we will now open up the executive
session on house spill 494 relative to
the fees collected under the New
Hampshire fertilizer law and the chair
will recognize representative almi for a
motion
thank you madam chair I'd like to move
on retain on this bill and I'd like to
explain uh the pieces of it that I
finally figured out two nights ago when
I bothered to look it up in dedicated
funds well we rely heavily on that but
could I have a second on the retained
motion
representative elberger seconds the
motion okay please yes inform us
okay and there is before you now
a page called fund name product scale
testing and Horticultural registration
under detailed activities it explains
that New Hampshire has specific laws
governing commercial feeds in commercial
feeds including Pet Foods commercial
fertilizers
agricultural liming materials and
Horticultural growing media
that is what it says
on and it talks about registration
labeling and testing
it says that the department samples and
test products each year to com ensure
compliance with label guarantees and
respond to complaints from consumers
there is a long-term need for the fund
balance to support a department
initiative to increase the number of
products
sampled and tested the fees that go into
this are only on commercial feeds they
are not on fertilizers which as I have
never heard of it being referred to as a
fee but as a feed before but
um
neither is Horticultural growing media
so on if you look up at the chart in the
top middle
on this account for at least four years
and as I recall when they came before us
I believe it was four five years ago and
that we'll be seeing them again this
year
before dedicated funds they uh
have a ending balance which is at least
twice their expenses
in this fund
so we have that problem why is the
commissioner not allowing them to do
fertilizer testing if fertilizer testing
is supposed to be done in here
but the other side of it is fertilizer
testing is supposed to be done in here
but at feeds is paying for all of it
and if they're doing fertilizers
at least half of what they're doing is
not feed
so
um
there's that question and also there is
a question that overlaps with the olpc
oplc bill
which is what is a legitimate legal
amount of surplus that should be
retained in a dedicated fund
we have dedicated funds that are doing
two three times
their expenses or more because they're
saving up to pay for a building because
the old one is falling into Lake
Winnipesaukee we've had funds that were
saving up a number of them saving up for
databases on and other ways to reduce
their their staff expenses or to be able
to do as in this case everything that
they're supposed to be doing according
to our laws
um but then there are others where the
balance just keeps growing
and that's what the dedicated fund
committee looks into every five years
but if we look into it as the dedicated
fund committee we will just be coming
back to Ways and Means and environment
and agriculture to to ask them to do
what we could do in a
study committee this summer
or fall
and
I I think that if
I'm not sure it's allowed but if we
expanded that that question to be what
is a proper
balance to keep in the fund
on that we might be able to solve part
of our oplc problem at the same time
yeah
I can certainly ask the speaker if he
would consider that Jermaine to a
retained Bill discussion
and if not certainly someone could
sponsor a bill yeah and we could do it
that way yes except that on study
committee is the second year don't work
very well
but
um it is
um basically we could study this in
terms of this particular bill but we
couldn't tell the old plc uh hint that
she had to come and talk to us in the
Comptroller together
uh well we could also we're going to
discuss this later of course but we had
another dedicated fund when Bill your
bill that we've already passed through
the house we'll see when it comes back
from the Senate that may be a vehicle we
could utilize
on
on you mean if if I got that that added
in the Senate
because we couldn't add it after it had
been to the Senate yeah something to
think about your weight there's
different ways to keep working on that
topic representative ulery did you have
something to say
no but the comments that the majority
and minority well Susan ah made
whatever uh are very appropriate having
and dealt just a little bit with oplc
and and some of the other uh dedicated
funds across the years uh referencing
the department of safety and the marina
building which was literally falling
into Lake Winnipesaukee uh some form of
legislation is needed there
I don't believe there's anything
preventing
um
any
particular chair or member from calling
a ad hoc Maybe
regarding this so
that may be another uh method but it's
definitely something we should address
and I'll be happy to co-sponsor any such
well not any such such legislation
yes we could certainly uh do a public
notice on a not if it's a non-germaine
Amendment and just on a particular bill
we can always as long as it's noticed in
the calendar we can certainly do that
yeah
we don't have any bills left except the
ones coming from the sentence true but
when we retain this bill we could do it
then
right other comments on the retained
motion on House Bill
494.
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
thank you madam chair representative
again
yes representative ulery
yes
representative Doucet yes representative
Pillsbury yes representative yes
representative Wallace yes
representative sodi yes representative
orrs yes representative roshwick yes
representative Almy
yes
representative Ames yes
representative Southward yes Professor
Malloy yes representative partial yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
Elber yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith
right here
okay
on the chair yes okay the vote is 19 to
zero
would any object would anyone object to
putting this on the consent oh no
there's no calendar to worry about it's
retained so we don't have to worry about
that okay great we will now close the
public hearing on House Bill 494.
uh I will now
open and then immediately recess the the
executive session on House Bill 607 the
prime sponsor has been working on an
amendment and he literally just got it
off the press has not even had a chance
to read it so we will uh recess that
until
well we need to get to the other one so
I'd say let's say noon for now okay and
we'll go from there okay so I will open
the executive session on House Bill 607
and I will now recess it to noon today
okay now we will open up the executive
session on House Bill 445 which is
related to
operational funds of oplc and the chair
will recognize representative ulery for
motion
move ought to pass with Amendment uh
two zero two three zero eight three four
h
uh uh just to confirm that's uh
Amendment 0834h
okay uh there's a motion to ought to
pass as amended uh would you like to
well we need a second for that
all right representative Olney seconds
that
representative Oliver would you like to
speak to your motion
thank you the primary uh Bill we
discussed uh in detail previously
requiring regarding the need for such a
fund uh within oplc all this amendment
does is reduce the uh excess funds uh
are capped at uh three million dollars
as opposed to five million dollars
um
this uh particular dedicated fund is
necessary to uh if you will tide over
oplc are regarding their various
operational uh deficiencies that take
place because of the current requirement
to lapse everything into a fund and it
follows along with the previous
discussion we had regarding the entire
uh dedicated fund structure thank you
representative Olney
thank you um
we just had a I just had a discussion
with Chris Shea to know how the oplc
survives now
because it is getting on virtually very
little money until six months after
they've had everything lapsed on and he
explained that with dedicated funds like
this they do the laps and then the
treasurer runs a negative balance
which is essentially on the general fund
but it has to be paid back by the end of
the year
um and on so
the the fund is officially paid for by
other sources which is the registration
and other fees that they get penalties
on but it comes out of the general fund
which just got the lapse it comes back
out of it to pay for their operations
until a they are
uh pay it off
other comments
yes representative fellows
so
having some experience from working
within a state agency
um
one of the things that's there there is
there's not a cash flow issue
with this this fund that they currently
have
um it's not it's not like a business
it's more like a school district or a
municipality where you appropriate money
and that gives the different agencies
the authority to spend that money
the revenue is is accounted for
separately and the fact that your agency
hasn't brought in
you know enough money from day one to
cover expenditures is not a problem
because when we vote on the budget we
establish the Authority for that agency
agency to spend the money they need to
operate to pay their employees and
whatever
so
you know that's just the general context
I see no reason for even needing this
at all to to change their fund at all
they they
make sufficient money so far they've
always been lapsing money at the end of
the year back to the general fund
I think that the amendment I'm not see
I'm not sure if I'm looking at the
amendment or the bill
part of it yeah that's fine so which
part of it has
giving them the authority to um
make Capital expenditures without going
through the oversight of the appropriate
Committee in the house to do that you
know we have a capital budget it's
therefore a reason
um to make sure that we really need to
to make those expenditures it's I don't
think it's up to
oplc to decide if they want to if they
want to buy a building to have their
offices in I think that's part of the
responsibility of other com of
committees in in the legislature
and they can they can get what they need
by making a case for it asking the
governor to put it in his budget asking
um the you know
appropriate committees for a Thor
telling them that they need
um new facilities if that's the case one
of the things that we know is that
there's definitely a proposal on the
table already to move Justice to the
building where Lincoln Financial used to
be we know that because we have already
approved a project to build the parking
garage on their site so we know that
building's going away and they need to
move somewhere else it may be more
appropriate if oplc needs office space
maybe that's the place for them to go
and that's a decision for administrative
services to make and not oplc so I see
no reason
for passing this
bill it all thank you thank you
representative and I should I did that a
little bit in a rush where technically
first voting on the amendment so the
amendment was moved so we'll be voting
on the amendment first which uh is
really putting a cap on the thing and
then we will vote on the ought to pass
with Amendment which includes the
underlying bill so I kind of joined
those together by mistake so I apologize
for that representative Ames
it's that's my mistake I'm sorry
Okay so
focusing on the amendment
um
I I find myself unclear on what changes
this makes from current law
I was just looking at what I have online
as current law
and it has no limit in it
what I'm seeing there's no in excess of
a certain dollar number
um is there is there a limit somewhere
else is it in the budget Bill maybe a
temporary limit
would you clarify this I believe in the
bill that came to us from the other
committee there was a cap on it or no no
you would have requested one and passed
it without uh requesting that Ways and
Means add a cap to it
which was the request to be DNA which
approved the policy of adding this to
the bill currently the uh what it says
in here is it's a non-lapsing fund so
the amendment changes it to I mean it's
elapses
and this changes it to a non-lapsing
fund and caps the amount of money
retained at three million dollars uh
currently as uh representative almi
indicated earlier uh what happens is the
money comes in
he gets sent back to the general fund
and it gets drawn on the general fund so
this is
then they run with a negative balance
until such time as they get that paid
off and then they have we depend upon
the licensing that comes in and and how
many fees come in and how many uh uh
investigations need to take place how
many hearings need to take place how
many people apply for oh there's a lot
of variables that take place so what
this does is sets up a uh
I hate to use the term but it's a
fund of money that they can draw from
without drawing from or drawing on not
from but drawing on the general fund to
cover operations
uh as representative Almighty explained
representative self-worth sorry I'm
sorry representative did you have more
to say okay
so this basically is a clarifying
Amendment
it really just clarifies the process it
does put a number in
well as far as the numbers go
representative all me it's reducing the
amount of money on that they can retain
permanently away from from the general
funding
um
I wanted to put a sunset on this
um that would take it back to uh
elapsing Fund in a couple of years
simply to be able to remember that we
need they are planning on all kinds of
changes which would make it less
expensive
so that we could take that cap down
further if it was so indicated because
but on
we tried to put it through Drafting and
drafting was not being responsive
so this is what we've got
just have to remember that uh we may
want to look at it again
as a committee uh representative already
did you have your hand up again or was
that Southwest yes I just wanted to
remind the community that we do have a
bill coming over in about a month
from the other body that's very similar
to this with some other language that's
coming through the idea being that uh
this makes an excellent uh platform for
working with the other body uh when we
sit down and mesh things together a
little bit later
representative self-worth yeah no I was
fine sorry
representative Platt I just want to say
we could pass this bill and if there's a
concern about
having a drop dead date it let to make
it lapse that can be done next year
for new bill
other comments from the committee okay
seeing none the clerk will call the role
on the amendment so the motion is ought
to pass on Amendment 2023-0834h
yes representative ulery yes
representative Doucet yes representative
yes representative yes representative
Wallace yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative Rochford yes
representative Army
represent Ames
represent partial
yes representative Malloy yes
yeah and I didn't skip sales threat it's
partial replacing him
Schaumburg I had in the wrong place
sorry
representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy
yes representative
Schaumburg
listen
impartial
yes
and in the wrong place my apologies
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith not here
uh and the chair yes okay photos 19. 01
absent okay being the vote is 19-0 the
amendment to House Bill 445 passes now
we will vote on the underlying bill as
amended House Bill 445 as amended by
0834 is there any more discussion well
do we need a motion on that yes we do uh
representative
ulery is recognized for motion I move
ought to pass as amended on
hb445 FN
is there a second second representative
Army seconds
now is there more discussion
representative fellows so thank you
madam chair well in addition to what I
said earlier
um I would just now that we know there's
a similar Bill coming from the Senate I
think that that would give us an
opportunity to maybe hear more
um technical
explanations of why you want a
non-lapsing fund
so that
because my objection is I see no
absolutely no reason for doing this and
also whether or not it's appropriate to
put things in there like that it will be
used for Capital expenditures which more
normally go through administrative
services so I would like to you know I'm
a
opposed because I would rather see the
spill it out and then that would give us
more time to take the Senate bill when
we get it and get more information
other comments
I I appreciate your concerns and we'll
be looking to keep a close eye on this
in the future okay seeing no more
comments I will introduce the Kirk just
call the roll thank you madam chair
representative
yes representative ulery yes
representative yes representative
hillsbury yes representative yes
representative Wallace yes
representative soti yes representative
orrs yes representative Rochford yes
representative Army
yes represent Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative paloy yes
representative partial yes
representative fellows no
representative Bolton yes
representative helberger
yes representative lippley yes
representative Smith
not here my president again sorry okay
the vote of the chair
yes okay the vote is 18 to 1.
consent
uh this could go on consent if everyone
agrees to consent uh representative
fellows would you like to have it on the
regular calendar
not not on the regular calendar but it
has an FN does that can we put an FN on
consent
depends on the dollar amount I think so
I don't know for sure
um do you know if it's I'm I'm not going
to
um oppose it if it and and I don't I'm
not going to oppose it because either it
can't go on the consent calendar or if
it does I'm not planning to speak
against it okay would you like to be
right a Minority Report
uh
no well I it would be great if we could
get it by the end of today
um but that we don't have to because
this bill actually is a second committee
bill so we we actually do have a little
bit of time
I will try okay I mean I can't get it
done today for sure but maybe by
tomorrow okay well a Minority Report
means actually tomorrow's not going to
be much of an option I don't think okay
well so yeah and so it The Minority
Report I representative almeid just
pointed out if you do a report then it
really can't go on consent because
consent is everyone consents that is
okay to go on consent calendar
so skip it okay no Minority Report it
will then go on consent calendar
certainly anyone has the option to let
the members of the house as a whole know
their thoughts through an email or
whatever so okay all right so we will
now close the public hearing uh so ought
to pass as amended does pass and we'll
go on the consent calendar and we'll now
close the executive session on House
Bill 445.
I want to just say hello to our friends
who are here substituting if you could
just say hi and tell us who you are what
committee you normally serve on that'd
be great
yes good morning uh representative
Wallace Rockingham 8 which is the town
of Danville I sit on as the vice chair
on Judiciary six years previously on uh
criminal justice
and I'm malicious partial over from
Science and Tech and
um I serve Marlborough and outside of
Kane and there's four other small towns
nearby
thank you for joining us today so we're
going to take a little bit of a break
right now come back at noon
representative Doucette has a proposed
amendment to House Bill 607 so he'll
pass that out and go from there yes
representative I wanted to get the
amendment before we broke so that we
could read it yes me too I haven't seen
it yet so yes he has those hot in his
hand right now
their worksheet technical or mechanical
defects sheet and by and large that's
what this should represent so I'm
comparing those notes to this
uh representative Doucette is going to
go back to OLS and bring those to their
attention it doesn't look like a lot
when we compare notes
um so hopefully we'll catch it and be
right back but we will now have to
recess
maybe a little bit later so if you want
to go get a lunch yes representative
Phillips so we were trying to check them
against this this document and so we
found that the first one wasn't
fixed
I think it was
um yeah I was looking for two voters
directly uh
they State the amendment is accurate it
correctly addresses all the technical
issues identified by the lottery uh
what's he reading the the lottery
worksheet was incorrect regarding the
expiration date of facility licenses and
the goe license lottery agrees the
amendment is the correct warding
what are you reading where's that from
it's a text message from someone at
Lottery uh
through another person yes okay so I'm
looking at the handout that we got
from the lottery and the updated it's it
stated that the lottery sent this to LBA
on 12 30.
let you know at the end of the year and
it's in the first thing on here it says
is on of the original bill
page two line 18 that the license
shouldn't be asking them to submit
something
um annually submit some kind of
statement on December 31st it said it
ought to be aligned with when the
license and that's not changed in the
amendment
it should have been
what's the page in line in the original
well on the original bill it's page 2
line 18. and on the amendment
so it's so it's Roman numeral three and
on the amendment that starts on line 11
and it still says December 31st
great catch well I'll address that all
so I only got through the first two
I think I have thank you original only
yes on I've got a question with page two
original on
d8
um Section 5 and the amendment uh it's
about the game operator employer license
application the person that owns the
thing
and it on in the original it
it which has been excluded now it says
in addition to the general requirements
under 287 D5 a game operator employment
license application shall include at a
minimum the following information
provided that the Lottery Commission May
by rule establish additional items to be
submitted on the application form or
attached to it and they were telling us
that if they had some suspicions about
the entity that was controlling that on
they would go from the
principal owner even down to people that
owned one percent of the operation on
and look at them and it seems to me like
this is being taken out at this point
and there's also it says if the
applicant is an individual then there's
going to be a photo taken
I'm wondering if there is
on
being a lot less
uh
on
license for the people on the groups
that
come in as
as
corporations or as LLCs that they would
avoid a lot of scrutiny that they would
if they were individuals
I don't know a lot about this area but I
would wonder why that section was taken
out
good well I can just mention that
representative Rocher brought up in the
um
in the hearing and the work session
concern about too much broad making rule
Authority and lots of bills in fact he's
looking at other bills in the same
regard so we as we talked about maybe
not having such carte blanche
rule-making Authority everywhere if if
it makes sense to put back under 541a or
something like that but it just was kind
of vague there and a bunch of places so
that's why that's there but I don't know
about the photograph you're talking
about the photograph Piece One Piece of
It is the photograph but then above it
there is the ability of the Lottery
Commission to by rule establish
additional items to be submitted on the
application form
that is just kind of it could be a
humongous list so if you'd like to have
that go through rule making so to figure
out what that list should be but what
are your thoughts
well I
it does say by rule
which I presume means it has to go
through a jail car
there are other places that it does say
under 541 but in some places it doesn't
so I don't know if that means that
you know if you look at page four on the
original bill it definitely references
541a but it doesn't in in several other
places which I think is kind of an
oversight probably because everything
does go through 541a so yeah
if yeah that all all the uh game
operators uh goe licenses are to a uh a
business entity so it's not going to be
affected by
uh what representative Olney speaking of
it they're not going through it the
license is applied with by a business
entity
but it
it's
not yeah I have a
memories on Ames
a comment or a question
um
there are I think three places where
the the
add-on that the Lottery Commission made
by rule established additional items to
be submitted to be submitted
um has been taken out
and
I I'd like to and I I know this means
retaining the bill rather than going
forward on it I'd like to hear from the
Lottery Commission what we're giving up
and I'd like to understand why you know
there may be this broader
argument that we're delegating too much
to the Lottery Commission I can
understand that argument but
um in this
instance
this is a long-standing program is there
some problem with what the commission
has been doing have we given too much
license to the commission
through through this kind of language is
that why it's being taken out I'd like
I'd like to explore it and we're not
going to be able to do that in the
couple of hours we've got uh here and at
the edge of the executive session
representative
yeah and I'd like to say they did tell
us some of what's being taken out when I
think I I asked how whether they
were exploring beyond the primary
employer
and now we're being told that it's an
entity which does that
if there isn't anything in there about
the individuals in that entity
on we really don't know who who is
especially if it's a new one we don't
know who's controlling it
and whether they have a record of
misdoing somewhere else
any other comments
okay well so let's have uh
representative Doucette go back to OLS
with some fixes and we will we will come
back yes yes but I I want to be clear
these these changes to those specifics
that we've just spoken about in relation
to the specific rules with with the
bling demo item for item I think
my perspective in looking at this wasn't
to negate the ability of Lottery to do
anything it was clearly defined in some
of these sections and it seemed to list
out a running list and I know I
discussed it with the chair and maybe
you can give some clarity to that
because I have no problem keeping this
in this isn't a a deal breaker in this
amendment but I think where the bases
are covered with the plain language
that's in that's in the bill itself and
the amendment
the most important thing is that we're
trying to correct the technical fixes
that were identified if they haven't
been done already so that's but we'll
make sure that we do okay point of order
yes representative does it make sense
depending on how busy they are for us to
do our quick lunch and then come back
and do it it sounds like a great time
for a lunch so we will
um so what I'll do is I'll open the
exact session on 60 House Bill 607 and
then I will immediately recess it
um to one o'clock and hopefully by then
we have a clean Amendment thank you very
much so we'll close House Bill 607 and
reconvene at one o'clock
yes representative would it be possible
to just get a sort of rundown on what
are the changes in this compared to the
last version
absolutely the only thing is one of our
Representatives just left I just found
out she has another amendment so we're
waiting for that oh I did not know that
so um
read through it and see and hopefully
um when the representative moves his
Amendment he will tell us what's going
on
okay this is different here
this has an addition
we will attempt to do this one more time
we will open up the executive session on
House Bill
and I should always remember to mention
that I am a charitable gaming operator
as well as my husband so the chair will
recognize representative Doucet to
introduce to make a motion
thank you madam chair I move
Amendment 2023-1024h
is there a second
I second that representative Bolton
seconds uh representative set would you
like to explain to us what this
amendment does most certainly uh not to
rehash what we spoke about this morning
but in a nutshell IT addresses the
four-page uh
bullet points that Lottery had given to
us prior to the hearing when we heard
this bill
um
IT addresses some specifics in relation
to
rule making and Lottery's rulemaking and
and brings out uh
and references specifically RSA 541a in
four different places that need to be
needed to be specified
uh let's see
it added some language that spelled out
uh specifics relative to different
levels of Licensing
sure and made some technical and
spelling typographical type errors were
corrected in this also
another discussion on Amendment forgive
me also another one at the end the
effective date
it would it would State uh instead of in
I believe the original Amendment stated
uh December of 24 it specifies that
sections nine and ten which are raising
the
Max bet from 10 to 25 dollars in the
tournament bet to 2500 would take effect
upon passage of this and the remainder
of the changes would take place uh post
after take effect after 60 days of its
Passage
of Elber I really would appreciate a
line by line here because I'm finding
some of the changes but I'm not willing
to vote on something if I don't have the
time to read all of them
representative do you have a man what I
keep looking at is from what we got from
Lottery the last page which is the
technical or mechanical defects and that
is what this is primarily trying to
address so I think that is what
this does but if you want to go through
it please
uh we can if that's what you would like
uh referring to
Lotter Lottery's uh technical or
mechanical defects and I'm told by
Lottery that they were all addressed if
you want me to go item for item I can do
that okay uh in the original Bill page
two line 18 facility
I will have to wrap into that
also page three line five
g-o-e
can you just give us the differences
between the two amendments that we got
this morning between the two amendments
the one that we got this morning oh sure
and this one sure that makes it so much
easier sure uh we corrected that
laughs
uh you're welcome to leave anytime you
need to yeah okay so if if the member
would be care to answer the question of
comparing the two different amendments
we're just talking about the two
different amendments
um
bear with me
okay the date was correct like I like I
laid out prior to the the effect dates
changed
the uh
the issue with that you had brought up
representative was addressed
uh relative to spelling a particular
section I'm trying to find it here
and forgive me I gave OLS my notes copy
I'm trying to find it myself
um and the four sections
where
and I believe we had a written down this
four sections where it specifically
calls reference to RSA 541a
that did not specify that in the
original
Amendment
we look on page two
I believe D9 which is line 19. reading
down into that at line 24.
uh in part it says in the in addition to
the general requirements under uh 287
and it continues on WE inserted
the language that says
and I don't know why it's not in italics
but
rules adopted by the commission under
RSA 541a
and establish additional items which was
there so it's basically specifying RSA
541a
and that
spelled out in three other places and
again I don't know why it's not in
italics for the committee
yeah it was definitely a rush job my
apologies
the the amendment is can't hear you
representative
the amendment is repealing and
reenacting
so
when they do that it's a lot harder for
us to see the changes
representative said there's a whole
bunch of things crossed out on page five
that was in the original Amendment based
on the requests of the Lottery
Commission is that correct that is
correct but again I don't have my my
notes copy I left it with OLX so I don't
know
we the committee should have all
received an email that confirmed through
Valerie King at Lottery that they're
they're uh concerns were addressed in
the amendment
represent Albert
the four places that I've found thank
you madam chair uh include on page one
under Roman numeral two
that's the reference to RSA 541a
and then further down the page
under number 5
287- D colon 8 the end of that paragraph
some more about 541a
um
then the one at
eight six
uh one at the end of the paragraph there
again referencing 541a
and
under seven Roman numeral two
at the second part of that paragraph
541 a is that yes and that one's in
italics for some strange reason so yeah
it's confusing
thank you I concur yeah
oops okay so we have
Amendment
1024 before us which has been moved and
seconded
if there's no more conversation on that
we'll wait for the clerk to get ready
yeah
but I wasn't keeping up all of my duty
the uh the adoption of amendment is
2023-1024h and who moved the new second
uh representative Doucette moved it and
was seconded by representative Bolton
thank you
I am now ready okay the clerk will call
the role on the amendment
10 24. representative again
yes representative ulery
yes representative Doucet yes
representative spilsbury yes
representative yes representative
Wallace yes representative Saudi yes
representative orrs yes representative
rosh yes
represent Army
yes representative Ames yes upper in
Southworth yes Professor Malloy yes
virtually representative partial yes
representative fellows yes
represent Bolton yes representative yes
representative leapley yes
and representative Smith not present uh
the chair
yes okay so the vote is 19-0 one absent
okay now
we have some confusion about another
amendment and and just so you know the
chair does not have to take all
amendments but I will of course if you
have one ready well
I I don't because what I what I asked
for them to draft was just for section
18.
are you looking at the original Bill 18
if you look at the original bill
so
actually
relative to the
you know
it's the it's the moratorium
thing
so I asked for them to change the date
from
what I thought was
January 1st 2024 to January 1st 2025 and
and they didn't draft it right they
changed it so the whole bill was except
for one piece was going to have that
date so I don't have an amendment to do
that whenever possible normally we
wouldn't be under such a deadline but we
are so we'll uh we will take another
motion from representative Doucet
thank you madam chair I move on to pass
on hb607-fn
is there a second
wait so I'm sorry you're moving on to
pass with Amendment as Amendment okay
and is there a second
representative okay representative
Doucette uh would you care to
speak to your motion
again uh
this committee's done a great amount of
work on this uh this is a
a pretty
deep subject but in a nutshell it kind
of gives us a it keeps Pace there's a
lot of housekeeping in this uh
it keeps us in Pace with the uh the
lottery as far as the max bet
uh and
addresses uh some technical issues that
were
laid out by Lottery and it also ensures
uh that
the HHR game
uh stays in control
uh
of Lottery and control Statewide
other comments from the committee
representative Ames
I I have a concern about this and it's
been expressed
before but my concern remains it's not
addressed by the amendment at all
um and as background I think it's a good
bill I
would have liked to have supported it
but there is an issue for me and it is
the it is uh the effect of section 18 of
the original bill
which repeals
um
the provision
that sunseted you have to go through
various steps here the sunset at the
provision that limits
the operation of these facilities to
entities that were already in business
um back when the
historic racing
law was first enacted
and um
just so that's clearly in everyone's
mind
that provision which this this bill this
bill
would continue in effect in perpetuity
uh says that in order to be eligible for
a license to sell paramutual pools on
historic races
an applicant shall have been game
operator employer licensed under RSA
287d as of May 1 2020 and still licensed
as of the effective date of this section
provided such sales are within the
enclosure of a facility at which the
licensee
holds its license activities under RSA
287d and that such facility is located
within the city or town in which the
licensee held its license on May 1 2020
um
and an application that is approved by
the Lottery Commission and a license
that is granted shall not be permitted
to be transferred or sold so this
freezes in place
um The Limited number of entities that
can
engage in historic gaming in a way that
I think is
is Highly Questionable and should at the
very least be subject to a careful
review
as a separate and distinct issue
um the difficulty I have with this
section is that it it goes to the
opposite uh in the opposite direction
and uh continues the uh
uh limitation of licensees
uh without any end point
there is as we know
um or some of us know a bill that's past
the Senate
SB 51 that sets up a commission and that
that
changes the date at which this limit
limitation
would come to an end
and
without that date this this limitation
would end at the uh I think it's the end
of this uh
fiscal year 2024
so I think that uh I I would have
welcomed an amendment I gather that
representative
fellows was trying to get such an
amendment that would have
extended this limitation for just
another year I would have welcomed one
that extended it for two years as does
Senate Bill 51 so that we could get our
really focus on this question but we
don't have those before us so I'm really
left with uh no option but to
oppose the ought to pass
um Motion in the hope that we can get to
the point where we can retain the bill
and work on it
and get something in place
early next year
other comments representative horse
uh thank you madam chair representative
Ames
is there a reason why we couldn't let
the Senate and the house versions get
worked out in conference
I mean I like the fact that we're
locking this in and it's not going to
get spread through all these communities
and you know basement operations or
whatever it could be so that part I like
and as far as the date I agree with you
I mean why can't we just let the Senate
and the house work that out at a you
know
shortly it's going to happen shortly
right crossover days just around the
corner
yeah well that's a good question I
respect that the
I guess there are two things I want to
say one is I agree with you
I don't want to see
um these operations
on every corner of every city or town or
whatever wherever they may choose to go
there needs to be a limit
um should there be just I think it's 14
right now besides that we're in place
and should they all be uh frozen into
the city or town where they are
currently located
um I don't think so
um maybe there needs to be some level of
monopolization allowed which is
essentially what that would do but that
seems kind of crazy to me uh the one
that's in here
um I think it is worth looking at on the
second part of your
your question your what you've observed
is that there is this opportunity to go
into eventually a conference with the
Senate and I've never really liked the
idea of endorsing something that I don't
like
as a way of getting into a conference
where we might lose so I don't really
want to go down that that pathway
that's me
representative oh sorry representative
Spielberg
thank you madam chair
I'm in favor of the bill and we'll vote
for it but I just want to go on record
with a concern and if this is unfounded
and someone can straighten me out that
would be great but
both the bill
and the amendment delete specific
instances
of
what would constitute a minor or a
moderate
or a major violation
and by doing that
I understand there may be some deference
to to The Liquor Commission excuse me
the Lottery Commission to to determine
that in rulemaking
but we leave them completely unguided
these distinctions are not incidental a
minor or a moderate or a major violation
each have a completely different range
of fines
and that's about as vague
and uncertain phraseology as you can
possibly imagine
minor moderate and major
are proportional
to what
and so I'm not sure why
the bill has deleted examples
those examples did not limit the uh the
Lottery Commission because in each case
it says may include but is not limited
to so in either case the the Lottery
Commission had the
discretion to create rules that might
cite other examples but at least these
gave guidance in terms of
proportionality and what we thought each
level was so
um
that's something I I unfortunately was
unable to attend the work session and
didn't have the benefit of being able to
lay that out here if there are any
answers but these are not terms that are
defined elsewhere in the statute so far
as I'm aware they're certainly not
evidently defined in this bill
you know I would just want to be on
record that that's something that I
think we might need to revisit
representative you said you have your
head up yes it and just uh I wasn't
going to bring up the the other body but
we do know that there's a mirrored piece
of legislation over there with a date
specific and and there is a process for
that
um
as mentioned earlier I just want to
clarify one thing because this can be a
confusing issue this is not
uh putting a moratorium on charitable
gaming this is very specific to one
electronic game that we passed into law
last biennium
and we in in many people's purview
don't believe we've had the time the
time that it was uh rolled out and the
time to review the impacts of that game
and this is kind of putting the brakes
on so this doesn't mean uh it negates
the the ability for any
person to become a charitable game
operator and take on those Charities and
and
generate revenue for both the Charities
and the state it just isolates this one
specific game until we find out what the
effect and the saturation point and
other issues are so I I don't want to
continue to punt this down the road and
I think we'll come together with what
the Senate produces but this is the
house side of things and we should dig
our heels in and and say we need to take
a look at this and it's not going to
negate charitable gaming
you know specifically it's one game
one specific issue and we need to to
take a good look at that and the best
way to do it is is to step back stop it
and take a good look at it thank you
representative
thank you madam chair
a hard time articulating
this so I may stumble a little bit as I
go
um
one of the
issues that I had with the um
premium cigars bill was that it had been
as I understood it historically set up
to protect an industry that we had here
in New Hampshire
the this bill
which
at least at this point says that the
only people who are that we will limit
the number of licenses for gaming
um is protectionist because as I
understand it if you have a license now
chances are pretty good that you'll be
able to continue with your license
and if we're doing that I would very
much like to see us
provide those licenses issue those
licenses to New Hampshire folks
which is certainly not the case now
I understand that's not the scope of
what this bill is addressing right now
but it does provide some concern to me I
did get a call from someone from the
Boston Billiards
um
group in Nashua yesterday telling me
that they had been bought out by the
Jacob brothers who own the Boston Bruins
and they live in Buffalo which really is
New England which
I found
interesting
um
but I am concerned that if we are going
to be protectionist and I tend to agree
I don't want to see games on every
street corner or even every other street
corner but I would like to see if we can
figure out a way at some point to make
sure that we're at least giving
preferential treatment to qualified New
Hampshire operators thank you
other comments represent Mommy
yes
um I'm having difficulty with this too
the paragraphs that representative Ames
showed me
essentially the way it's worded is I
understand it on
you we could end up with one very large
operator forcing or buying the others
out and there would be one license in
the state
on and if we're looking at
at a total ban
and I have a great deal of trouble
having watched them over the years with
Committees of conference there are times
when the leadership wants a particular
outcome and they just remove a person
and put another person on that will do
what they want that outcome to be and it
looks very different from what the
committee had
um
and
on
I'm not really sure what to do at this
point because on it's more probable that
um this provision
number 18 is going to go the way of the
dodo as soon as it hits the Senate and
that one way or another they won't
discuss it in the committee of
conference
but it is amazing
quite a concern given the way that that
that is worded which was worded when
people were thinking that in four years
it was going to be expanded
so thank you
any more discussion
yes representative
um I can somebody explain to me
section 18 because I thought that was
one of the corrections that was going to
be made what does it just tell me
exactly what it does and when
that it wasn't in the amendment it's
just it's only in the basic bill
representative Doucet I'm not exactly
sure the correction you're referring to
on in section 18.
section 18 yeah next to the last
no I'm I'm asking what was the
correction you were referring to
representative I'm not sure
what is eligible in 2024 I thought when
we had a discussion you were going to
put in
either July 1 or January 1.
or
this is back from me so what does this
do
and when you're talking about the
effective date no 18.
original bill
because it's not in the amendment it's
only in the original bills yeah
yeah so it would
say it's effective on on Passage
60 days
yes
the the way it's written my
understanding it would repeal that
statute and it would be on the effective
date of this
UH 60 days after its Passage
it's not 18.
well
section 18 was in I don't believe your
Amendment
touched section 18.
no mates
my my Amendment did not put the Billet
at its core does it repeals 287 D5
I'm sorry reading the wrong
so it says repeal
20.
forgive me representative it would
repeal uh
2021 uh 66 colon 10 relative to the
licenses it would negate that historic
horse racing uh eligibility
uh in that would stop in uh 2024 would
repeal that and it would revert to the
language in this piece of legislation
would that would be effective in 60 days
after its Passage
any other comments before we take the
vote Yes so when does it get repealed
according to the amendment 60 days after
passage right
well this bill would repeal it the the
original bill will repeal that effective
because it's not section 9 and 10.
is that how
if it
representative spillsburg yeah I think I
can clarify
in Reading uh section 18 on line eight
page nine that eligible in 2024 has
nothing to do with repeal that is from
the historic horse racing statute
so the effective date is entirely
governed by the amended section 19. oh
okay I was thinking that eligible in
I don't know
I thought it had something to do with
facilities eligible now okay okay thank
you
we have attorneys drafting this is
attorney speaker the clarity for lack of
a better term the moratorium that's on
HHR right now that's what that date's
specific to
so the moratorium goes away
on on in in the uh in 607 it becomes
permanent
60 days after Passage
the moratorium becomes permanent okay
it's kind of like double negatives so
okay so the motion before us is
ought to pass as amended by Amendment
2023 10 24 h
the clerk will call the roll thank you
madam chair representative
yes president of ulery yes
representative Doucet yes representative
spilsbury yes representative yes
representative Wallace yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative yes
representative Army
yes
representative Ames no representative
Southworth no
representative Malloy no
represent partial now
representative fellows
no
representative Bolton yes
Representative no
Representative leapley no
representative Smith is not here and the
chair
uh yes
the vote is 12 to 7 one absent okay the
vote being 12 to 7 the ought to pass is
amended vote
carries
uh I assume there'll be a Minority
Report
will there be will there be a Minority
yes and representative Ames
will be responsible for that as soon as
humanly possible but before you leave
today in the next hour
because the clerk is you're already
emailing me
uh representative Doucette
uh majority report will also be
necessary thank you ASAP within the next
hour thank you okay yes representative
ullery
no we voted on ought to pass as amended
we already had voted on the amendment so
I think we're good
um so that will now close the exact
section on House Bill 607 and uh
uh except for two people you get to go
home and then we'll see you tomorrow as
a house session which starts at 9 00 a.m
so please be here for that
no it starts at 9am for everyone
and it could be a long day guys but I
don't think we have any ways and means
stuff on the calendar so we've got it a
little easier
um and then don't forget next Tuesday at
10 A.M we have our full committee work
session on House Bill 639
so make sure if you can take the time to
read the bill again and become prepared
with questions and thoughts on the
revenue type stuff
thank you
foreign